of the new Coulter Welcome Center is
like the new front door of Carnegie
Mellon it's a place where our visitors
can come and be welcome to the
University they will be able to get
information that they need for their
destination and really learn firsthand
about all the innovative and exciting
things happening at Carnegie Mellon I'm
so excited that this is a place that
will be able to be a destination for our
visitors all in one place where we can
tell the story of Carnegie Mellon they
can catch a tour be able to see
information about the campus here
they'll be able to engage with our staff
and our ambassadors but also they'll be
able to see a microcosm of life at
Carnegie Mellon I want our visitors to
come explore and visit campus really to
understand what a great place Carnegie
Mellon is this is an opportunity for
this to be their destination while
they're on campus and we can't wait to
welcome them when they're here